بصرف النظر عن كيفيه التحضير يبقى البيض
وجبه شعبيه في الكثير من المناطق ولكن على
مدى العقود القليله الماضيه حذر الاطباء
من الافراط في تناوله خصوصا ان البيض
نسب عاليه من الدهون اما الان فالكثير من
خبراء التغذيه يقولون ان بيضه واحده
يمكنها ان تكون جزءا ضروريا من غذائنا
اكدت الدراسه تلو الدراسه على مدى العقود
العديده الماضيه ان تناول البيض لا يرتبط
بمرض القلب التاجي ووفقا مايو كلينيك فان
الحد اليومي للفرد من الدهون يبلغ 300
ملغرام في حين تحوي البيضه الواحده قرابه
ال 186 ملليغرام من الكولسترول ولكن في
نفس الوقت تحوي 13 نوعا من الفيتامينات
والمعادن الاساسيه والكثير من البروتينات
ومضادات الاكسده الجيده للقلب وبمعدل 70
سعره حراريه
فقط نسبا عاليه من البروتين وايضا
عناصر هامه جدا لصحه العين كذلك لصحه
الدماغ وفيه نسب مرتفعه من فيتامين دال
الضروري للعظام ولنظام
المناعه